alors il commence il vous caresse le le
haut du corps il vous caresse le visage
et un jour il vous dit laisse-toi faire
sur un ton qui n'est pas un ordre mais
quand même relativement autoritaire
quand on y repense est dégoûtant
et elle nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20h ce soir Joël devine et donc
pour son livre témoignage
violé par un prêtre aux éditions de
l'arbre alors Joël bonsoir à un moment
où l'implication indirecte du frère du
pape Benoît XVI dans un scandale de
pédophilie en Allemagne braque à nouveau
les projecteurs de l'actualité sur
l'Église catholique les éditions de
l'arbre rééditent votre livre témoignage
violé par un prêtre l'histoire d'un
enfant qui cherchait de l'affection et
qui n'a rencontré que de la perversité
et la destruction personnelle vous
écoutera à 20h
[Applaudissements]
avant d'aborder notre histoire je
voudrais qu'on regarde un édito de
Blacko
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est bien prudent d'inscrire
ses enfants au catéchisme si c'est pour
apprendre l'amour du prochain pourquoi
pas mais bon il y a des limites alors
d'accord tous les kurumes sont pas
pédophiles n'empêche il y a des curés
pédophiles partout le scandale a d'abord
éclaté aux États-Unis puis en Irlande au
Brésil au Pays-Bas en Autriche en
Allemagne aussi où le frère du pape est
accusé de ne pas avoir dénoncé les abus
sexuels commis dans la chorale qu'il
dirigeait et le pape lui qu'est-ce qu'il
dit
et ben en 2008 à Sydney Benoît XV a déjà
présenté les excuses de l'église aux
victimes australiennes peut-être qu'il
devrait renouveler ses excuses mais
cette fois dans toutes les langues au
balcon de la place Saint-Pierre
aujourd'hui pour que l'Église prouve sa
volonté de lutter contre la pédophilie
certains voudraient qu'elle renonce au
célibat des prêtres malheureusement même
si l'écurie devenaient paire de famille
ça ne règlerait pas forcément le
problème car en France 75% des cas
d'agression sexuelles sur mineur jugées
au tribunal sont des cas d'inceste non
non
tais-toi maltraitance et violences
sexuelles sur mineur se taire c'est
laisser faire voilà c'était l'édito de
Blacko mise en images de Julien grappe
alors Joël votre famille
habite un petit village belge à la
frontière de la France de la Belgique et
du Luxembourg qui s'appelle Aubange des
gens assez pauvres votre père est
grutier dans une casse automobile votre
mère femme au foyer vous avez trois
frères une sœur et vous avez huit ans
quand votre père perd un œil dans un
accident de voiture et du même coup il
perd son travail
il se réfugie dans la boisson
voilà mais moi je ne lui en veux pas du
tout parce que à sa place j'aurais fait
pareil son accident il a il avait 33 ans
donc avec les enfants
à nourrir alors là vous avez du mal à
étudier chez vous au milieu d'un père
alcoolique et de frères très bruyants et
vous vous rapprochez du vicaire c'est à
dire du curé du village et des
religieuses qui l'entourent et là c'est
assez agréable finalement parce que vous
sentez aimé et choyé à ce moment-là je
les prenais comme ma famille quoi voilà
je faisais mes devoirs chez eux je
faisais leur jardin avec eux tout ça le
course vous devenez un petit peu Joël le
sacristain de la paroisse à ce moment-là
et vous vous envisagez même à l'époque
de devenir prêtre ça vous semble
pour moi c'était un bon exemple de vie
de voilà alors c'est alors que le
vicaire tombe malade et arrive un
nouveau qui s'appelle la baie
il y a des jeux il y a des consoles
Nintendo il y a il y a un baby-foot
enfin les jeunes viennent facilement
chez lui il faut dire que c'était en 87
donc
il est à l'avant-garde comme je dis
maintenant ce serait l'ordinateur il
aurait l'ordinateur chez lui tout de
suite bien sûr alors il y a un truc qui
nous semble quand même bizarre c'est que
dans son bureau qu'on vous y allez vous
découvrez beaucoup de photos d'enfants
encadrés quand même c'est surprenant et
un fauteuil c'est tout il y a la
télévision un fauteuil donc chaque fois
que tes enfants venaient il fallait
qu'ils se mettent à leur sourire sur les
accoudoirs sur ses genoux ou par terre
sur le tapis mais ça c'est calculé c'est
à l'étage donc c'était réservé pour les
enfants et quand il recevaient des
adultes il allait recevoir en bas
alors il vous invite à aller le voir
quand vous arrivez il ferme les volets
il allume la télé et il vous demande
effectivement de vous asseoir sur ces
genoux et moi comme j'avais un petit
frère qui venait de naître
j'étais j'avais pas trop eu d'affections
dans ma famille comme ça et de voir mon
petit frère dans les bras de ma maman
tout ça et qu'après je voyais tout des
enfants chez le prêtre moi je me suis
dit pourquoi pas moi et donc lui il me
disait mais viens tard le soir on sera
tous les on sera tous les deux et tout
de suite ça a dérapé alors il commence
si vous caresse le haut du corps il vous
caresse le visage et un jour il vous dit
laisse-toi faire sur un ton qui n'est
pas un ordre mais quand même
relativement autoritaire voilà et moi je
n'aimais pas je fermais toujours mes
yeux alors là il commence à vous
caresser sous vos vêtements de plus en
plus bas ils vous embrasse mais sur les
joues sur les oreilles c'est quand on y
repense est dégoûtant
faire du trou la sexualité je
connaissais rien du tout
vous dites
quand même au bout d'un moment il vous
demande quand même des choses plus
précises il vous force à le masturber
force à des fellations quand même aller
plus loin mais ça j'ai toujours résisté
quand même quand vous dormez chez lui il
essaye d'aller plus loin dans le lit et
vous refusez à ce moment-là
oui parce que ça c'est pour moi c'est
déjà je voyais que c'était pas c'est de
la bestalité enfin voilà alors vous
décidez d'en parler à l'évêque
auxiliaire du diocèse et puis vous
n'avez pas de réponse et vous pensez en
fait que ces pratiques sont habituelles
parce que vous avez pas de référence
s'il ne me répond pas c'est que c'est
normal quelque temps après il a quand
même dû partir le fait il a été dans une
autre paroisse près de Namur et là il a
recommencé il est resté dans l'église il
a pas été exclu de l'église rien en
aucun cas alors vous devenez ces minaris
vous découvrez que le psychologue qui
est chargé de soigner votre timidité est
en fait complice de toutes ces
magouilles c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
pendant pendant que vous lui racontez
vos histoires lui il se fait un whisky
coca il s'en fout il répond au téléphone
tout ça moi il me dit de m'allonger sur
un divan je dois sentir le cœur battre
au bout de mes doigts et trois quarts
d'heure après si j'ai senti le cœur
battre au bout de mes doigts ou pas il
s'en fout que je dise oui ou non
l'argent c'est tout
mais après des années après je me suis
rendu compte que je m'étais laissé mener
en bateau parce que ce gars-là est
devenu prêtre après donc les vêtements
voyaient chez ce psychologue parce qu'il
savait que ça allait rester étouffé
enfin la baie
reconnaîtra l'effet l'église vous
encouragera à ne pas porter plainte
devant la justice des hommes on vous
disant ça doit se régler entre nous mais
déjà il n'a pas avoué rapidement parce
que un pédophile n'avoue jamais il faut
des preuves et avoir des preuves c'est
difficile mais moi chaque fois que je
lui écrivais lui il me répondait il me
disait je ne le ferai plus je
recommencerai plus je j'ai tout gardé et
donc quand il a nié à l'évêcher il y a
une réunion au tribunal de l'église il a
nié mais j'ai dit je vais apporter les
lettres et là elle a dit non ben ça va
j'avoue
et là il a demandé un arrangement il
fallait pas étaler la faire sur la place
publique et il voulait un arrangement
l'amiable donc l'évêque avait dit bon on
payera ton psychologue un tiers le
prêtre fautif l'autre tiers et toi
l'autre tiers parce que si tu payes pas
une partie de Tapie elle marchera pas ça
c'est le psychologue caddie ils n'ont
jamais tenu cette engagement voilà vous
êtes exclu du séminaire donc et ils font
traîner les choses parce qu'à moi il y a
prescription en Belgique c'est 10 ans
après la majorité
alors ce n'est qu'à 27 ans que vous
déciderez de porter plainte alors
effectivement au procès il est
finasteries terribles entre pédéras et
pédophile parce que ils disent à 14 ans
c'est un adolescent c'est plus de la
pédophilie c'est de la pédérastie puis
même il est venu en dire que c'est moi
qui demandait
vous dites ils ont volé mon corps ils
ont détruit ma foi
moi je ne crois plus en rien depuis
parce que l'évêque est là pour dire la
Parole de Dieu soit disant
je me suis rendu compte que l'évêque m'a
menti sans arrêt donc comment croire
après à leur baratin de l'église voilà
et c'est ça le problème je pense avec
les pédophiles prêtres c'est que il
confesse tous les jours et il se dit
j'ai le pouvoir de pardonner au nom de
Dieu n'importe quoi Dieu lui va me
pardonner aussi aujourd'hui vous n'avez
plus la foi non non non non
non non j'ai un chien c'est grâce à lui
que je vis pour lui voilà c'est mon
soutien c'est tout est-ce que vous avez
eu connaissance d'autres cas que le
vôtre plusieurs fois il a donné le bain
d'autres enfants devant moi donc c'est
pas le rôle d'un prêtre
mais selon vous pourquoi l'Église a
tellement mal à régler ce genre de
problème parce que peu de victimes ose
porter plainte déjà alors il y a déjà
beaucoup de prêtres pédophiles qui
abusent mais ça s'est jamais et après il
meurt personne n'a porté plainte contre
deux si quelqu'un osent le dire à leurs
parents maman le curé fait ça la maman
elle va avoir peur de
oser porter plainte du qu'en dira-t-on
des voisins tout ça donc elle va les
trouver l'évêque et dire voilà je sais
ça déplacer le prêtre ou on porte
plainte et donc ils vont déplacer le
prêtre sans rien faire mais le prêtre
ailleurs va recommencer et la famille
les parents ils sont contents parce que
comme ça ne le voit plus il faut des
preuves aussi c'est difficile de dire on
va pas aller comme ça dire voilà le
prêtre m'abuse mais il faut des preuves
et trois si quelqu'un leur va aller
porter plainte les ex va essayer de
faire des arrangements l'amiable pour
pas aller en justice c'est ce qu'on a
essayé de faire avec moi et moi j'ai
toujours refusé
je préfère même perdre les procès et pas
avoir un franc que ne pas sur les procès
et d'avoir de l'argent de l'église parce
que le prêtre lui il s'en sortirait trop
bien Joël est-ce que vous croyez que
s'il est prête pouvait se marier comme
les pasteurs comme les rabbins ça serait
mieux non il y a beaucoup de pédophilie
inceste dans des familles donc si le
prêtre se marient déjà abuser de ses
enfants donc voilà il y en a plein qui
comment dire qui ont des copines qui
sont ça c'est aussi à notre problème que
un tabou que l'Église ne dit pas il y a
le célibat c'est de la connerie
il y en a plein qui sont père
mais aussi l'église tout est bien
calculé dans le Notre Père par exemple
pardonne-nous nos offenses comme nous
pardonnons aussi à ceux qui nous ont
offensés donc d'office à la tête bon le
prêt de m'a fait du mal je dois lui
pardonner parce que Dieu me demande de
pardonner j'ai mis une lettre d'un prêt
dans le livre qui m'insulte parce que je
crache sur l'église soit disant c'est de
la foutaise parce que Jésus Christ de
votre côté voilà voilà est-ce que vous
croyez que Benoît XVI va vraiment
s'attaquer à ce problème ça c'est de
l'hypocrisie puisque en Irlande il y a
eu des scandales découverts par l'État
ils ont fait une commission d'enquête
qui a duré des années il y a quatre
évêques qui ont démissionné le pape n'a
déjà accepté la démission que de 1 mais
là le pape parle de l'Irlande mais si on
lit ses discours il y a 4 ans il parlait
déjà de l'Irlande donc c'est chaque fois
des excuses mais à part ça il y a rien
et ici en Belgique il y a un évêque un
procès en cours il a une promotion ça va
pas il y a d'autres prêtres qui sont
pédophiles ils n'ont pas de problème on
des places de paroisses c'est tout je
connais
il y a beaucoup de choses qui ne sont
que les victimes devraient médiatiser et
comme ça la bombe les quatrième fois
pour toutes en Amérique ils ont été
obligés de payer quand même oui mais le
problème de dollars voilà les données
par l'Église catholique à des enfants
victimes de pédophiles quand même alors
ça c'est pas bien c'est ce que je dis
dans le livre parce que là en payant le
procès n'a pas eu lieu ils ont accepté
un arrangement l'amiable et ça c'est pas
bien dites moi Joël ils ont bousillé
votre vie quoi bien sûr et moi mon papa
est mort à 59 ans et jamais José lui en
parler il a vu ça dans un journal un
jour que j'avais autorisé de mettre ma
photo je suis né dans le fin fond de la
Belgique j'habite à Bruxelles je me suis
exilé à Bruxelles parce que j'avais peur
d'aller dans mon village parce que des
gens croyaient que
les rumeurs tout ça que c'était moi le
pédophile donc moi on m'avait mis dehors
du séminaire parce que j'étais pédophile
alors que j'ai été abusé et que le
prêtre lui il se pavane partout ça va
pas
c'est le monde à l'envers puis moi j'ai
médiatisé l'affaire aussi et puis j'ai
porté plainte parce que je sais qu'il
faisait ça à d'autres et je voulais
qu'il y a d'autres plaintes et qu'il
aille en prison c'est sa place mais
voilà c'est vrai il y a plus de
tolérance de la société sur ces
choses-là non je trouvais pas parce que
c'est une honte c'est un tabou on n'ose
pas le voir
merci de votre témoignage dans tous les
cas Joël
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu